35,783 Atraxa players need to see this.
I see you play Attra so you didn't even
bother to scroll down when looking for a
commander and your deck is probably just
the top 99 cards on EDH wreck. But no
problem, I do the digging for you. The
card is savor the moment. Okay, I'll
hold for you to read it. Just kidding.
YouTube shorts are only three minutes.
You won't be able to finish. But let me
find you the keywords here. No, no, not
this one. Take an extra turn. Skip your
untap.
99.38% of you all are not playing this.
Do you understand what this card does
with Attra? It's three mana for one more
proliferate and it draws you a card.
Why? Because you know what? In the extra
turn, yes, you skip your untap step, but
there happens to be a draw step. Oh, and
I hear you talking. Uh, what about
Tedarus Gambit? That that proliferates
and draws us two cards. Two is better
than one, right? Oh, you know what? In
the extra turn, yes, you skip your untap
stat, but there's also a main face. Two
of them even. That means you can use
your planes walkers another time or tick
up your sagas. Your opponents think,
"Oo, I have one more turn." No, you
don't. Tefairy ultimate. Oh, I have two
more turns. No, you don't. You're dead.
And also, did you know that Tedra's
gambit costs two life, but savor the
moment gains you four life? Why? Because
did you know that in the extra turn,
yes, you skip your untap step, but there
happens to be a combat phase. Attra has
vigilance. Vigilance says attacking
doesn't cause this creature to tap.
Doesn't untap. Doesn't tap. I'm going to
let you figure this one out.